[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
émission un peu spécial parce qu'on est
en plein salon du livre des premières
nations donc on a eu envie de faire un
facebook live pour vous permettre
évidemment de savoir ce qui va se passer
au salon mais surtout de découvrir des
nouveaux auteurs vous allez être surpris
je pense alors la première fois j'ai
fait et fouilles à facebook live moi je
vois tout le monde devant moi mais je
sais que quand on parle on ne voit
qu'une personne à la fois alors je dis à
mes invités vous serez seul à l'écran
quand vous allez parler
donc je vous les présente et je commence
par mégarde le picard signer parce que
vous êtes de directeur du salon du livre
des premières nations bonjour bonjour je
devrais même dire coups et à en coin
voilà où en êtes vous oui merci de nous
rejoindre parce que c'est aujourd'hui le
on est mercredi c'est le premier jour du
salon du livre des premières nations et
donc ça nous fait plaisir d'être là pour
commencer les activités avec vous j'ai
tout de suite passé à nos autres invités
parce que je vais dire tout de suite la
thématique
ce sont les jeunes auteurs et là
j'exagère un peu pour eni limonest
emilie bonjour onesearch très jeunes
sauteurs coup et jeunes auteurs ce n'est
peut-être pas tout à fait exact dans
votre cas mais vous écris depuis
longtemps mais c'est la première fois
qu'on publie une de vos oeuvres
ben en fait de leur credo est quand même
assez récent pour moi moi c'est plus du
milieu à des arts vivants en fait mais
y'a toujours l'écriture mais ce n'était
pas la chose
primordial dans ma pratique artistique
est là en fait j'ai fait un spectacle au
sens du terme aujourd'hui en 2018 est
bon c'est un théâtre donc le théâtre
c'est on part d'un texte
et voilà donc c'était un texte décrit
pour la scène qui maintenant été publiée
aux vertes rouges location et ça
s'appelle au kingdom ouais et puis notre
eau très vite et il est temps à une
maladie mais bien de l'acadie mais il
n'est pas en acadie actuellement ces
chaînes michael jeune poète bonjour
chaigne coup et oui bonjour je dis oui à
tout le monde parce que dans chacune de
vos communautés que ce soit chez vous en
tant que mal et si chain chez vous en
tant que anishnabe emilie ou encore en
tant que wendat oui car on dit quoi et
c'est le même ou dans les trois langues
alors voilà exactement scène mike horn
vous êtes un oui jeudi un jeune auteur
c'est votre premier recueil de poésie en
fait est ce que c'est votre premier
écrit que vous publiez
oui exactement c'est vraiment premier
texte
j'ai déjà que des petits brouillon ici
et là mais c'est seulement mon tout
premier texte d'accord et vous avez créé
fort ça s'appelle fif et sauvage et vous
allez nous expliquer tout à l'heure
pourquoi vous l'avez titré ainsi mais je
reviens tout de suite je reviens tout de
suite à un louis karl may carles
rapidement parlez nous du salon du livre
là qui commence qu'est ce qui va se
passer il ya énormément de choses mais
rapidement est ce que vous allez mettre
l'emphase par exemple sur ces jeunes
nouveaux auteurs ben vous voyez cinq
années peu importe la confond en
présentiel comme d'habitude où cette
année en virtuel nous notre mission
c'est toujours de décès d'avoir une
programmation la plus diversifiée
possible mais en ayant raison des gens
qui sont plus connus du public qui ont
déjà publié est que bon qui attire aussi
des du public mais de faire découvrir
des nouveaux auteurs ç'a toujours été
important depuis les tout débuts de sa
lancée on y eu la chance nous
voir les débuts de naomi fontaine de
marie-andrée guilde plein d'autres
routeurs autres risques sont aujourd'hui
très connus qui sont en demande que que
le public en redemande encore mais oui
nous allons commencer quelque part c'est
tellement une force vive chez les
premières nations dans toutes les
disciplines artistiques d'ailleurs mais
nous évidemment ce qui nous intéresse
d'avantagé c'est le texte c'est la
littérature
donc c'est important pour nous chaque
année d'inviter les auteurs qui publie
pour la première fois donc c'est pour ça
que ça me fait grand plaisir d'être là
avec avec scène et il me dit aussi parce
que bon évidemment il me dit on la
connaît jusqu'à parce qu'elle oeuvre
depuis un certain nombre d'années
antérieures puis je pense que c'est
vraiment de leader dans son domaine
oui en tant qu' en tant que coo triste
ben tu vois un réel vient de publier
pour une première fois il pour nous ça
ça mérite d'être célébré ça mérite
d'être célébré ça mérite d'être souligné
et ça mérite d'être partagée avec le
grand public qui cette année ben c'est
notre petite planète bleue gazon se
tourner vers emilie et vergers est y en
a plusieurs cette année des nouveaux
auteurs on a quelques uns quand même
c'est sûr qu'avec la pendue nice elle a
un peu ralenti l'ensemble du milieu un
temps les éditeurs les presses qui ont
fermé aussi un certain moment donné ça
donc c'est le pauvre faciliter le pense
que d'abord d'hésitant un gros retard
dans leurs rangs et en retard dans leur
calendrier de production
n'empêche on eu quand même quelques noms
bon il me lit et scène bien sûr on à
félix perkins aussi qui sera avec nous
on a dans les nouveaux nouveaux comme je
vous dis en a pas tant que ça montre des
gens par contre comme eve ringuette qui
est assez connu du public en tant que
comédienne qui nous a écrit un texte
pour notre syrie à survivre au temps
donc tous les jours du salon et un texte
original
inédit autour de la thématique survivre
au temps qui est qui et postés sur notre
site web et donc cinq nations
différentes représentées on aère qui est
une comédienne innu qui a accepté de
nous écrire un texte original donc on a
donc déjà disons d'autres artistes qui
s'adonne aussi à l'écriture qui sont
indiqués même s'ils ont pas
nécessairement publiés oui c'est qu'il
félix que je pense que félix publie dans
la même maison d'édition que c'est une
personnelle chez personnage c'est ça
ouais félix quinzaine de résine wendat
mais qui demeure dans la région de
houston et au nouveau brunswick et donc
ça ça fait partie de disons que d'un
partenariat que quoi y'a tant que
personnage l'éditeur de moncton a
développé pour justement
professionnaliser des genevois
autochtone du du nouveau brunswick en
fait en français parce qu'on sait très
peu de topcon qui parlent français au
nouveau-brunswick mais quand même la
région du madawaska elle qui est qui
multilingue et on y retrouve des
malécites qui qui parle qui écrivent en
français donc on a un partenariat avec
personnages pour professionnaliser ses
auteurs à les amener à une première
publication
et disons pour notre première une
première année de projets bon les gens
ces personnages sont concentrées sur
scène et félix et ses deux ouvrages
extraordinaire d'ailleurs que les gens à
découvrir des voies différentes et sont
notre besoin et d'ailleurs ou pas parce
qu'il est là l'homme et chen je trouve
ça extrêmement intéressant aussi
justement vous parlez de son titre on va
le laisser en parler mais pour moi la
diversité dans l'écriture autochtone est
importante ça fait partie de notre
richesse trop longtemps il ya eu ce
stéréotype locke bon la littérature
autochtone de la littérature historique
ou basés sur des légendes ou sur ou sur
le territoire puis oui c'est vrai ça
demeure vrai que ce sont des sources
d'inspiration mais en même temps
c'est pas ça la littérature autochtone
pas plus qu'on peut cantonner la
littérature québécoise en disant oh la
littérature québécoise c'est c'est le
sur 20 ans pour la littérature du
terroir c'est juste ça c'est pas vrai et
en littérature autochtone c'est pareil
c'est pas vrai on peut avoir
on a déjà une diversité et cette
diversité la s'accroît d'année en année
et moi sur ce tellement important
tellement intéressant et le livre de
chêne daste contexte là vient
véritablement ouvrir quelque chose en
littérature autochtones francophones qui
était pas le convoyer du côté anglophone
mais très peu du côté francophone c'est
à dire que par une double
marginalisation dans le fait d'être à la
fois autochtone et même la communauté
lgbt qui plus est je pense que autres
n'en parlera plus que moi mais je pense
que le titre de son ouvrage sans
équivoque justement retourner tout de
suite alors verschelde pourquoi avoir
titré votre recueil de poésie parce que
c'est un recueil de poésie fyfe sauvage
fait savage d'enfoncer un le titre m'est
venue sans hésitation que la foncière
représente beaucoup un bon parcours en
tant que personne aussi d'un parcours
identitaire justement j'ai passé par
l'intimidation j'ai passé par toutes les
difficultés les réalités qu'on vit
aujourd'hui donc c'est pour ça que cif
pour moi c'est le premier mot qui m'a
été dit avec l'intimidation
donc c'est pour ça que c'est sur mollo
qui sait ce qu'il ya différentes façons
de comparer fait faire un autre mot par
exemple dans différentes mais fils tu es
le plus le plus global pour moi et
savage c'est aussi la même chose c'est
le thème qui souvent dit par exemple
dans la communauté le corps ça c'est des
sauvages qui habite dans ce sont les
plus traitées comme sauvage mais c'est
certain que ça a évolué depuis donc mais
ça fait que dans mon recueil j'en parle
beaucoup aussi d'être trop tard je tends
à 20 heures c'est des choses que qui
montrent à quel point que j'ai de la
difficulté à me retrouver face à tout ça
donc je suis le petit est en fête et
sauvage enfoncé leurs
je suis un peu pris entre les deux noms
qui sait où des côtes et d'accepter les
deux ensembles signe de vivre une partie
si dans un reee dans l'autre séparément
de se détacher de ce fait qu'ils ont
c'est vraiment un gros cercle de
continuellement chaque jour revit ces
expériences le de me retrouver sur une
longue période de temps
voilà donc c'est vraiment sur ce
parcours d'être en retard mais de
vouloir replonger dans l'écologie ce que
j'ai pu faire ma part c'est mais c'est
de retrouver mes racines de retrouver ma
langue
la prendre toutes les choses que j'ai
mis de côté dans le passé que je veux le
sait le temps même si je suis jeune
auteur mais c'est quand même le fait
d'évoluer dans tout ça et tous vos
poèmes tourne autour de ces thèmes dans
certains cas des mamans que sais je
parle en plus les stéréotypes je parle
beaucoup sur le rejet de ma culture ou
si je meurs comme si je me détache
complètement les questions qui relèvent
aussi je parle aussi de ma mère qui
c'est un thème qui est assez fondamental
dans mon texte qui tous une grande
source d'inspiration majeure qui a fait
partie de ma vie qui a été la personne
que j'étais le plus près avec toute mon
enfance
elle est décédée dix ans passés donc en
2010 d'un cancer donc c'est sûr que
cette marque l'homme serait resté en moi
donc on les voit dans mes textes aussi
le petit côté de ma mère c'est ce que ça
donne une bonne sensibilité on voit la
sensibilité aussi dans mes textes
le côté qui purent qui les a volés
l'émotion qui sont évoqués sont quand
même à 5 ans donc je pense que ce petit
côté des motions clients dans les textes
aussi que même un peu plus de vie à des
textes mais je trouve ccc la sphère de
dire les vraies choses aussi que j'aime
bien c'est pas trop directe dans le
village de mon usine oui oui oui
alors qu'on va revenir tout à l'heure à
vous parce qu'on a le temps on va vous
demander de lire un des uns de vos
poèmes dans votre premier ouvrage publié
en même temps saura s'il y en a d'autres
en travail on va se tourner vers emilie
émilie o'connor donc premier premier
texte publié un texte que vous avez donc
écrit en 2018
que vous êtes en résidence entendez je
le reprends cette âme je les sensibilise
j'aime pas aux saints pères
d'aujourd'hui
oui c'est ça sent du théâtre
d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs vous dire vous
travaillez sur autre chose on va en
parler mais revenons sur okinawa
pourquoi les avoir publiés ben en fait
tout simplement parce que il y avait
quelqu'un de réservé rouge qui est
sylvain lavoie qui dirige la section
scène dans cette maison d'édition qui
venus voir le spectacle lui qui m'a
évité à le publier
donc j'ai trouvé l'exercice est
intéressant aussi parce que ma pratique
et très sonore donc dans le spectacle et
beaucoup d'enregistrements sonores
par exemple on suit mon parcours
d'apprentissage de la niche d'un démo
wayne avec ma professeur véronique tasci
donc il ya beaucoup d'entrevues donc
immédiat avec comment est-ce qu'on veut
pouvoir retranscription en format papier
littéraire donc eu tout une adaptation
d'un spectacle interdisciplinaire dans
un livre en fait finalement donc ça se
travaille et est super intéressant à
faire donc oui ça part d'une invitation
tout simplement
alors l ouvrage dont qui sort dans les
trois langues les trois langues qu'on
retrouve dans votre dans votre pièce au
kingdom et là encore pour vous c'est est
important que les trois hommes les trois
loups qui en fait qui sont le fondement
de votre vie aussi à vous avez vécu dans
ces trois langues là qu'on les retrouve
au tendon dans des vide à man dans la
pièce que dans vos écrits
ouais bah c'est les trois langues de mon
identité en fait finalement mon père est
français de france donc
la langue première c'est le français
mais ma mère est anglophone mais bon
elle après par les français avec mon
père mais elle nous a toujours parlé en
français même si elle part en anglais et
l'année chine a des mots in qui est la
langue maternelle de mon grand-père et
puis voilà et moi c'est un processus de
réappropriation aussi de cette langue là
et ça passe beaucoup par la pratique
artistique finalement oui est ce que
d'ailleurs dans parce que vous êtes vous
êtes toujours en fait encore au centre
du théâtre d'aujourd'hui
vous travaillez sur une deuxième
création je pense à saper le marguerite
oui c'est ça oui marguerite est ce que
vous êtes très avancé dans ce travail là
actuelle mais j'avance j'avance le texte
n'est pas complètement fini mais mais
oui j'ai quand même pas mal écrit enfin
c'est pas encore finale mais oui ça
prend ainsi sur la vie de marguerite
duplessis qu'était la première personne
autochtones au canada ou au québec à
avoir eu un cas juridique et la première
esclaves ou six à avoir eu un cas
juridiques pour faire reconnaître sa
liberté
donc on part de l'inscription de son
procès en 1740 mais aussi le texte que
j'ai écrit et puis de champ que j'ai
composées aussi et le travail se fait
encore là dans les deux ou trois longues
non non là c'est vraiment juste en
français donc voila mais bon
le corps est aussi une autre langue ou
un autre langage la voix aussi donc pour
moi il ya à la fois le texte le corps et
puis et puis la voix aussi qu'ils sont
trois formes de langage qui se tissent
et s'entremêlent dans ce spectacle oui
tout à l'heure le week-end nous parlait
de bons de certains thèmes par exemple
le territoire la transmission wii qui
sont des thèmes qu'on associe souvent
aux autochtones
on le retrouve quand même d'en haut qui
nomme c'est un peu ça mais au kingdom
évidemment nous ramène aussi à
aujourd'hui au présent mais nous ramène
dans le passé
bah oui je pense un peu comme chez ses
devanciers pour moi c'était un spectacle
un peu comme un accouchement de ma voix
d'artistes tous et donc est quelque
chose de vraiment très personnel et très
en lien avec mon identité mais identités
multiples et comment je les fait
cohabiter en moi donc sa part finalement
d'un rêve récurrent d'un castor géant
que j'essaie de déchiffrer qui m'amène à
vraiment visiter ma lignée familiale en
fait des femmes dans ma famille jusqu'à
mon arrière arrière grand mère donc sur
cinq générations et qui fait aussi
allusion en fait à ce moment-là on
m'avait dit agnostique et un cancer dans
la gorge donc c'est un peu tout mon
processus de guérison mais à travers à
travers ou à travers un fait finalement
un parcours identitaire aussi louis
carles
quand vous vous tourner vers ces jeunes
auteurs
est ce que vous attendez quelque chose 2
moi la seule chose que l'amour - mort
mon travail c'est de mettre leur travail
en valeur en fait je ne m'attends à rien
de bien sûr on espère que les gens vont
continuer ils vont avoir une carrière
parce que à quelque part si on veut
soutenir on veut les faire connaître
c'est parce qu'on espère qu'ils vont
continuer à créer ils ont cette force
vive le bon c'est sûr dans le cas emilie
ça fait des années que fait ça alors on
espère qu'elle va re publier une pièce
c'était l'hiver j'ai eu le plaisir de
travailler avec les mini par le passé
pour prospecter clé bon c'est toujours
un grand plaisir la retrouver mais moi
je viens de oui bien sûr j'ai de la
scène aussi mais bon c'est surtout
littéraire donc quand je vois ces
légendes de la scène qui viennent et tu
publies leurs ouvrages sur ce thème
important vous savez moi une formation
une histoire gd une autre politique de
religion en fait j'ai défroqué cugnaux
l'engin mais ce qui est important ce que
les gens en or n'ont pas tous en art
visuel parce que c'est une vie aussi de
ce milieu là et de la danse et ça on ne
peut être moins de reflex en théâtre en
visuel de documenter vous voyez que tu
écris un texte ce qui va être là dans 20
ans tu peux y retourner
et moi je trouve ça important même que
ce travail comme commissaire c'est
important pour moi d'avoir toujours au
moins un document
c'est un mini catalogue one piece kull
pour qu'on garde une trace dans le temps
parce que le théâtre est joint en visuel
il ya quelque chose d'éphémère là dedans
la scène fait partie de la richesse et
de la beauté de la chose le disons au
lait mais en même temps quand on peut
avoir une trace dans le temps qu'on
documente le parcours de ces auteurs de
ces autres issus de ses créateurs le
sursaut tellement important pour le
faire découvrir à des gens qui peuvent
pas nécessairement être là aussi dans
l'espace et dans le temps et ça me fait
penser entre autres tout à l'heure vous
m'avez demandé il ya eu d'autres
nouveaux auteurs ben y'en a un autre
j'ai oublié que je devrais pas c'est
juste l'un si oui bon ont connu la
caisse technologie avec mon objet parce
que bon nul
ils ont travaillé midi et moi avec avec
jocelyn déjà pour le théâtre et josselin
qui est un homme de théâtre et plus
précisément un homme de théâtre d'objets
donc théâtre de marionnettes qui vient
tout juste de sortir mon oncle je les
lui aussi c'est la même chose si ce
parce que il travaillait sur le
spectacle qui nous ont dit non mais
c'est important d'en faire un livre vous
cite il ya tellement et il ya travaillé
les deux en même temps
d'ailleurs je pense que jocelyne ne sait
plus s'ils y adapter le show à partir du
lait vous le livre produire du spectacle
c'était deux projets que construit en
même temps et ça donne une forme
particulière bien sûr il y aura
probablement plus d'infos dans le livre
que dans le spectacle parce qu'un mot a
mené un spectacle on peut pourtant pas
éternisé le spectacle non plus ouais
c'est ça parce que le livre bombe de
plus d espace pour développer mais ce
sont ce merveilleux parce que je suis a
été un artiste extraordinaire aussi que
suit avec grand intérêt depuis de
nombreuses années et l'a d'ailleurs
beaucoup coûté les gens savent aussi
adapté chronique de kitsch qui est là en
spectacle littéraire donc j'ai eu
l'occasion de retravailler relativement
récemment avec et souvent ça il faut que
ce soit aussi un livre ce qui me parlait
de manque justement beau projet il rien
d'écrit ou presque à part quelques
heures c'est très savante et sur sur mon
nom sur sûr je le cite oui alors soit
c'est important que ce soit un livre
aussi est la réponse que maintenant elle
est très très bonne de son volume
les sources sauf antastique parce que
oui on veut créer des on veut on veut
amener des nouveaux auteurs à la
publication à la professionnalisation
mais on est aussi un plaqué d'artistes
incroyable que ce soit justement en
théâtre ou au cinéma ou en arts visuels
qui ont des choses intéressantes à dire
et je pense que d'autres comme moi
personnellement je suis extrêmement
heureux quand ces artistes l'eau font le
saut du côté de la littérature
savoir est-ce que ça continue on va
vérifier avec shake parce que vous shane
justement vous êtes formé en théâtre
vous êtes formé en danse aussi vous
faites de la danse et vous vous êtes
lancé en poésie d'ailleurs pourquoi
avoir choisi un moment donné de publier
d'écrire des poèmes de vouloir publier
en fait le théâtre c'est la première
chose que j'ai fait comme or en fait
l'école au secondaire c'est une forme de
thérapie
c'est la seule chose que j'avais une
idée en tête de faire de la seule chose
qui je fais en ce moment que je préfère
dans le futur donc c'est là que je me
sens lié un an dramatique à moncton
nouveau brunswick
j'ai fait deux saisons mais c'était très
pratique mais je trouvais qu'il manquait
de la théorie donc j'ai décidé de
violence en théorie donc être capable de
réfléchir sur pas juste un personnage
mais aussi sur l'environnement du
personnage d'où il vient c'est beaucoup
de recherche si ce que j'aime beaucoup
donc ce que j'ai vu à l'université laval
je suis venu ici donc spécialisée a mise
en scène et dramaturgie donc on va
vraiment tout
c'est ça que j'ai étudié la danse est
elle beaucoup plus sain complémentaires
pousserait à 4,6 une formation
autodidacte qui parce que je trouve que
le corps est important comme méthode de
travail
tous mes textes que je vais écrire j'ai
besoin de bouger avant que ça sorte
comme photoshop du moule donc ça
m'inspire beaucoup
j'ai comment j'avais pas beaucoup la
lecture et l'écriture avant 2016
je crois que ce n'est pas lui qui m'a
pas écrire mais tout d'un coup un jour
je me suis dit il faut que je découvre
autre chose on dit que je trouvais que
au théâtre ça va plus loin que c'est la
danse il faut jamais plus loin que ça
donc sauf que le cela s'appelle dans la
peinture aussi faire de la peinture
éphémère sous les étoiles sans réfléchir
à ce que je vais faire donc c'est quand
même abstrait l'écriture j'ai commencé à
écrire tout ce qui me venait à l'esprit
sans juger ce que j'écrivais mais je
mettais tout côté tous mes projets
d'écriture je les mettais de côté on
lens a jugé aussi nos textes sont
écrites la première fois j'ai un ami
sébastien bérubé vu mes textes inspirés
mais motivé comme mon bras droit à ce
qu'ils font elles pas retrouvé cette
petite flamme là aussi en soin de
terminer un projet d'aller jusqu'au bout
donc pour moi une fois que j'ai accompli
mon premier texte a expiré à aller
pouvoir comment des gens jettent encore
encore soif pour lui de nouvelles
expériences découvrir ma culture on est
tous trouvent à soyaux mambo comme c'est
magique ou alors on aimerait bien vous
entendre dire un des poèmes de votre
recueil votre premier recueil fif et
sauvage je vous ai demandé d'en choisir
un donnant-donnant lire qu'est-ce que
vous avez choisi j'ai choisi
j'ai choisi la moisson qui est c'est un
texte ce qui représente un peu tout
l'intérieur comment qu'on est bien
fermée comme ça qu'on a discuté après
chez des gens la violence que ça peut
créer donc soit canton ce combat si on
se doit chaque jour où si tu me que
notre culture autochtone on se base sur
le même l'homosexualité communauté
diabétique
on a discuté avancer on est toujours
souvent en train de reculer par ça mais
ça va de mieux en mieux pour certains
endroits mais ça montre à quel point que
en dedans ça brûle ça chauffe
c'est difficile de se permettre d'aller
avec l' influence des gens aussi autour
de nous il faut s'adapter
dans des situations comme ça puis c'est
parfois difficile
laisse moi
va dès ce soir je sors de ma cage ce
soir je voyage dans tes yeux amalgame de
terry cole tu de ta fierté à mes yeux
innocents
ma peau écorce de bouleau vulnérables
qui enveloppent peut-on charme mais aux
dents dos mon coeur pas lâche mes yeux
griffes de loups mes lèvres plumes
colorées pour toi tu m'as semble me
sable le poly mus culte me lamine
hurlements bêtes assoiffées je te désire
mâchoire luz à travers tes yeux
s'accrochent les miens
ton regard est vide suis-je allé trop
loin je me prend par le coup mais pousse
contre le mur me frappe au ventre me
tourner la tête
les trophées aux murs la tête de ma mère
et celle des autres passages
le luxe se sourient mon corps mouillés
de larmes feuilles d'automne délaissé
sous la première tempête la cage vide
prête pour le prochain jeu
aucune trace je sais quoi tes yeux une
car quand vous avez lu la première fois
les écrits de shenzhen vous avez comment
vous avez réagi en fait dans le cadre du
partenariat comme c'est le dit lui-même
il était cbcb sébastien bérubé ces
personnages qui coordonnait un peu le
projet puis qui travaillent avec les
auteurs d'abord mais bon bien sûr
ensuite mes séances patrice thibodeau là
qui est le directeur de la maison et moi
même qui avons revu le recueil un peu
donné quelques commentaires gestion
hauteur pour bonifier le texte mais moi
dès la première lecture j'ai su québec
expose l'aude de glorieux de se dire on
assiste à la naissance d'une voix et ça
c'est toujours excitant dans notre
domaine de constater de planfoy de
réaliser tout d'un coup cas voilà on a
une nouvelle fois qui est en train
d'émerger
maintenant pour l'accompagner je pense
qu'on aurait été trop critique c'est une
choriste savez il ya beaucoup de gens
qui travaillent dans le domaine écrit
l'éditeur souvent bon bon bon bon vent
est assez critique des textes pour
pousser mais jean s'améliorer avec les
nouvelles voies moi j'essaie surtout de
voir ce que vaut ce qui est bien ce que
d'original puis décide de développer
plus ce volet là mais dans le coaching
c'est très très clair dès le départ
qu'il y avait une voie qui est l unique
et qui amenait un message ou des
émotions qui était particulière qu'on ne
voyait pas dans le spectre littéraire
autochtones au québec
puymoyen des textes qui m'ont
profondément touché une série de textes
entre autres est ce que c'est la série
qui s'appelle le festival chaîne
j'hésite mais celle où c'est une fille
vraiment l'intimidation le média
le micro agression j'écoute à dire une
série de textes incroyable où il cite un
paquet d'activités du quotidien dans le
quotidien ajoutait le quotidien c'est ça
dont chaque chaque petit moment du
quotidien qu'un enfant ou un ado un
jeune adulte pu vivre mais qui dont la
chute à la fin c'est toujours de façon
peu innocente voix mature fakhri me
faire traiter de fils me faire traiter
de sauvages me dit et il se trouvait que
cette série de textes là était magique
parce que elle démontrait elle faisait
vivre aux lecteurs ce que c'est que ces
micro agression là qu'on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui locle et jambon bon pour
faire des liens évidemment avec le
racisme systémique aussi tout ça donc a
cédé bien qu'on simple mais gens se
rendent pas compte
comment la goutte d'eau qui se rajoutent
qui serait tout peut faire souffrir les
gens et ce j'ai trouvé ça d'une beauté
incroyable et une vérité incroyable en
fait dans le texte de chaîne et c'est
cette série et dont lola de poèmes du
mois qui m'a séduit tout de suite là il
se savait qu'on avait quelque chose
après c'est sûr que toujours du travail
du travail dur travail à faire en fait
un manuscrit vous le savez ici s'est
jamais vraiment terminé il ya juste une
date de publication
et après ah bon tu fais mieux sourire
mais c'est aimer fini puis on le publie
puis après vont continuer à l'adapter à
le changer sur scène kandel le bénéfice
de le faire super enchantés de cette
rencontre avec scène par le texte et
avant d'écouter un extrait de haut qui
nomme donc un ouvrage d'emilie comment
vous l'appelez emile et vous l'appelez
ans j'ai beaucoup aimé d'ailleurs c'est
une auto fiction poétique
oui
oui oui oui parce qu'il ya quand même
des éléments dans le texte qui sont
inventés non quand même un moment donné
j'ai une scène je suis sous l'eau et je
dis que je peux rester sous l'eau quatre
minutes mais c'est pas vrai il ya des
éléments inventé aussi maintenant c'est
pour ça que c'est une offre fixe
alors eh oui oui car quand vous avez lu
la première fois les écritures que vous
l'aviez déjà vu sur scène
mémé de lire ce qui est écrit comment
vous l'avez ressenti en fait dans mon
cas moi je dirais que c'est plutôt de
redécouvrir l'univers des milices et
boncelles 15 robots dans le code de de
tat surtout dans l'oeuvre d'emilie où le
corps une place très importante où la
voix une place extrêmement importante
c'est cécile faux vive fauve est
l'oeuvre des milliers avant tout par
contre le fait de l'avoir par écrit
c'est plutôt d'un ex big thing et dans
mon cas moi c'était de redécouvrir la
voix des militants
c'était le moment c'est tellement je
dire on eu l'occasion d'en discuter
ensemble et plusieurs scènes que j'ai vu
dans d'autres contextes dans votre
spectacle ou dans d'autres moments de
diffusion donc pour moi c'est un petit
côté nostalgique peut-être le fait de
retourner dans le formol dans
l'adaptation livres pour avoir pour
avoir vécu ces cinq là et en partie de
façon du temps bien sûr mais en partie
le parcours l'évolution du projet quand
même le bon bout taille il s'est
profondément touchant c'est ce bon quand
on parle de mon soutien que demain que
le cancer et tout ça pour moi c'est ça
vienne nous chercher en tant qu'être
humain et l'au delà de nous de nos
conceptions ou de nationalité je pense
que quelque chose de une exploration
chamanique ces jeux ya quelque chose de
vraiment très profonde ans de têtu tu as
là et il faut il faut lui à défaut de
pouvoir y est
ben on va demander à humilier nous or
lire un extrait donc aucune homme ça
veut dire barrage qu'est-ce que vous
avez choisi comme l'extrait alors c'est
un extrait de la scène 2 qui s'appelle
la petite chasse et voilà donc c'est la
première fois que je m'en vais à
l'hôpital pour recevoir le diagnostic
cette nuit j'ai rêvé que j'étais sur les
lignes de tram avec mon cousin
j'ai rêvé au lièvre pris dans un collège
je les bus débattre longtemps gelé vu
essayer de s'arracher aux crocs du piège
qui lui serait de coûts les regarder
sans bouger fasciné par cet instinct de
vie qui est plus fort que tout j'ai
regardé dans les yeux du lièvre
comme pour saisir cet instant furtif ou
d'avis échappe ou la respiration cesse
où la vie quitte le corps de l'animal
mes yeux dans les yeux du lièvre gelé vu
mourir devant moi le lièvre blanc comme
la neige
j'ai admiré sa lutte jusqu'à ce qu'il se
résigne jusqu'à ce que son corps arrête
de trembler jusqu'à ce que son coeur
arrête de battre il est mort devant moi
sans un cri sans un jaillissement dans
le silence de l'hiver j'ai alors dépecer
le lièvre
je l'aide est vêtu de sa fourrure
blanche sa chair rose exposé dénudées
son corps encore tiède
j'ai regardé les gouttelettes de sang se
répandre sur la neige et je me suis dit
qu'il y avait rien de plus beau que ce
rouge
cette offrande de sang qui s'étale sur
le blanc puis une voix dans mon oreille
cake of cam a dit wen qui habite à main
mon coeur bat un peu plus vite en me
remémorant ses mots mais s'en tire son
coeur qui bat c'est sentir qu'on ait
envie non et la vie depuis que j'ai
trouvé la bosse depuis que je suis entré
dans cette danse des échographies des
mammographies des biopsies des scans des
aiguilles rentrée sous la peau la vie ma
vie sans que ça pulse très fort en moins
comme un barrage qui veut céder comme si
d'être confronté à ma propre mortalité
m'emmenait à vivre tous plus intensément
gérant
vous à l'hôpital ce matin en fait je me
sens comme le lièvre dépecer exposé une
érables à vif on peut voir la page
couverture de l'ouvragé
mouais c'est moi sur un lob de castor à
mixer mon approche de là où on a notre
chalet dans notre terrain donc un bac à
tort oui c'est magnifique dont publié
chez les herbes rouges
oui c'est vraiment beau un week end
franchement le cas d'ailleurs c'est
tellement formidable d'entendre des
auteurs lire des extraits ce qu'on va en
entendre plusieurs camps dans un salon
du livre au écoutez vous avez l'embarras
du choix pas vraiment beaucoup de
lecture
bah vous savez d'habitude ono vingtaine
d'auteurs cette année on est au delà
d'une cinquantaine d'auteurs autochtone
qui participe d'une façon ou d'une autre
mais la principale façon dont une
participent c'est par des lectures mais
toutes sortes de lecture c'est à dire
que on a des soirées tous les bons
chaque soir du salon on commence ce soir
mercredi avec le salon sur votre divan
ou renomme chez l'un à caubeyres train
via landquart guy sioui durand et
d'arômes cloud qui nous lie en français
alors ça c'est quand même quelque chose
on avait invité d'un ordre que publié
mascate je lis tu as quelque part c'est
sûr que je l'aimé je le vois non je
pense que dans mon autre bibliothèque
dresse avec son livre a été traduit en
français cet hiver c'est super u en
français mais je suis au yen mardi une
lecture on croyait qu'elle est nous
faire lecture en anglais
un homme s'est donné la peine de nous
faire une lecture à partir de la
traduction de son ouvrage ensuite demain
des lectures en anglais demain soir
jeudi donc willingness to you avec
tomasz king qui nous fait une lecture de
son dernier saut dernier les indians
indications sannois cambor tamgho et
noir
tu veux d'intérieur david robertson donc
ça c'est des activités plus de lectures
classiques je vous dirais mais après ben
on tombe dans d'autres types de lecture
entre autres emilie est saine d'ailleurs
participent tous les deux à l'activité
ça parle aux images qui est une activité
un beau programme de vidéos littérature
que à coordonner jonathan lamy
mais c'est vraiment incroyable puis
écoutez c'est sûr que c'est moi qui
dirige la programmation mais qu'on a des
commissaires ou des invités comme
jonathan
c'est intéressant parce que j'ai des
belles surprises vous voyez 13 arrêts le
produit fini ou presque là bon des fois
il dit qu'il a justement de montage et
tout ça mais quand je vois arriver le
produit pratiquement fini ça a été
extraordinaire pour moi je dis des
belles lectures vidéo de d'emilie
d'heuchin demain également d'une
pléthore d'auteur qui participent à
cette activité
ça va avoir lieu tu avais diffusé samedi
à 17 heures on parle entre all de
marie-andrée guînes mario draghi le
pardon voici ce combat comme félix
perkins kathia rock & aliens liam
simpson et d'autres excuses et il manque
quelqu'un non je pense mais autres
coffres
donc soit un bon programme de 45 minutes
quand même de vidéos littérature c'est
vraiment à ne pas manquer leur et il ya
d'autres occasions mais si vous regardez
le programme moi j'évite les auditeurs
bien sûr à regarder le programme on a on
en a de nombreuses lectures découvert
mardi soir
ouais puis balade lecture parce que vous
parlez de lecture ce jour-là mois une
activité pour laquelle je dis faible je
veux être avec toi être franc avec vous
on est toujours malgré tout qu'on ait un
programmateur ont toujours des préférées
et là je suis folle en conflit
d'intérêts parce que c'est moi qui ai
travaillé j'ai eu l'occasion de
travailler sur un projet il ya deux ans
qui s'appelle tracer un chemin
ça va utiliser
dimanche à 13 heures et très sincèrement
c'est des capsules audio qui avaient été
produites par l'institut tshakapesh
réalisé par les éditions année narac
mais bon il m'avait engagé pour
coordonner un peu le volet lecture de ça
il s'était par des capsules audio qui
servent en classe au secondaire c'est
pour les compréhension orale et donc
sont cinq auteurs autochtone qui
visaient des textes tirés de tracer un
chemin qui est un livre publié chez
nérac pour saignement des littératures
autochtone en classe et ses capsules au
sélect hurla aux mondiaux ont été montés
avec la musique était composé pour ça et
ça devient des chansons se dire si des
oeuvres à part c'est au delà de la
lecture et c'était pas accessible
nécessairement grand public
c'était pour le volet scolaire et la
barre grâce à une entente avec sa cape
et son on peut les présenter dans le
cadre du salon un sujet qui ont été très
généreux et accepter qu'on puisse
l'utiliser dans le cas où ce salon et on
en a fait un montage vidéo ou le pot
pour pouvoir identifier les auteurs qui
lie tout ça donc ça va être présenté
sous forme vidéo mais c'est vraiment
quelque chose que tu mets tes écouteurs
tu t'installes sont divers ou si ton lit
peut apprécier tu peux partir dans un
voyage de cinq auteurs différents
on parle ici de cas pêche à nantes n'est
qu'à push mais il est lu par naomi
fontaine joséphine bacon marie-andrée
guilde virginia précise map est au bord
de l'eau et moi même qui avait lu un
extrait de chroniques de critiquer
d'ailleurs c'est fini avec ça c'est un
bon texte plus humoristique de vrai dire
les deux pendant ce temps dans la ville
avoisinante
donc c'est vraiment c'est devenu des
oeuvres audio est sûr c'est intéressant
aussi le pur pour l'avenir le ce passage
le trial audio oui et entend qu'on dénie
la pandémie est un malheur mais pour
nous la chance d'avoir des auteurs dans
notre salon pendant les cinq prochains
jours c'est assez extraordinaire
vraiment alors on va bientôt terminée
mais avant que se dessécher j'aurais
aimé savoir sur quoi vous travaillez
maintenant oui
moi c'est certain que publie mon texte
était déjà je pensais pas que ça les
texans premier temps donné j'ai étudié
en théâtre performance devant public et
officiel avant mais finalement c'est le
sexe qui venant prévu mais je travaille
sur un one man show donc j'aimerais
vraiment intégré la danse le théâtre la
poésie et la peinture tout dans le même
projet donc c'est ce que je travaille en
ce moment c'est le confinement ils
entendent émis un peu aidé à focus
directement sur tous
mais je crois que tu dis si tout va bien
l'année prochaine voire voir le jour et
sinon je travaille aussi sur d'autres
textes en traitant ça ne la seule emilie
de votre côté vous êtes toujours donc en
résidence au centre du théâtre
d'aujourd'hui
vous travaillez sur marguerite est ce
que bon qu'est ce qui se passe ça c'est
pour bientôt si on le verra un jour sur
la scène du centre
oui oui oui il ya une diffusion qui est
prévue au printemps on a une résidence
au diamant à québec aussi en février
mais sinon je travaille en fait sur une
version audio podcast en quatre épisodes
qui nomme avec la scène nationale du
sont donc ça va venir au mois d'avril et
ça c'est intéressant c'est de penser à
comment adapter une pièce de théâtre ou
un spectacle interdisciplinaire à un
objet fait pour des écouteurs ou à
l'audio et puis c'est ça donc je viens
de terminer une résidence pour
marguerite et puis on fait aussi une
balade au qui va accompagner le
spectacle dont on a fait plusieurs
entrevues là avec différents j'aime bien
et entre autres la première juge
autochtone au canada donc pour vraiment
sont d un peu plus les thèmes du sytème
l'inde qui sont reliés à l esclavage
autochtones c'est à la justice à
l'amnésie collective qu'on a par rapport
à certains pans de notre histoire
collective etc
et puis le week end ces jours ci vous
travaillez sur salon du livre des
premières nations en fait tout est prêt
j'ose espérer que tout est prêt à
écouter c'est sûr que on est un peu
on est séparés dans l'espace en théorie
mois à partir d'aujourd'hui me résultats
stressé c'est ça l'essentiel de ma job
et à prier que tout est bien en suisse
évidemment j'ai nîmes je connais mais
aussi les pestacles bâtard donc c'est
fort d'une réunion tantôt avec mon ami
andré levesque sioui qui coordonne notre
show de fin de soirée
tous les soirs le salon donc ça aussi je
sais que des couches store des fois
comme moi qui aime changer de ce qu'ils
ont vu dans journée alors je vous invite
tous et toutes
venez faire un tour on a des live tous
les soirs à 21h le le pestacle bator où
on digère un peu notre journée
d'activités on a deux concours on a des
invités surprises aussi alors je veux
être moi c'est sûrement au rôle pendant
le salon rendu lola une fois que tout
est fait à part parler aux journalistes
c'est vraiment de préparer le show de
fin de soirée
voilà mais je vais vous souhaiter un
très bon salon louis carzou carte picard
si oui dont directeur du salon du livre
des premières nations
bon salon à vous aussi et bonne suite de
projets emilie monnaie et shane mike
horn
merci d'avoir été là pour pour cette
émission bien spéciale bien
intéressantes sur les hauteurs
autochtone merci beaucoup à une
prochaine
[Musique]